hey what is up guys mkbhd here remember
oppo that company oppo remember them uh
they posted a bit of a teaser a couple
of days ago on twitter that i retweeted
that reads hashtag
five was the first smartphone with a 5
inch 1080p display
hashtag find 7 is taking it one step
further
always improve and then it shows this
image that shows the oppo find 5 has a
1080p display obviously and that the
oppo find seven its successor is going
to have a 2k display
so many things about this just get to me
alright so first of all only oppo like
only oppo would tweet the next gen specs
of the successor to their current device
that they're currently working on that
no other company has ever introduced yet
they're then only oppo would tweet and
tease something like this second of all
what exactly is a 2k display if you
watched my 4k explained video you know
that the k is a shortening moniker for
the horizontal resolution of the image
of roughly 4
000 by 2000 pixels so doesn't that mean
1920 by 1080
is already 2k
roughly i guess the hashtag always
improve would suggest that oppo has a
slightly higher resolution in mind i'm
thinking 2560 by 1440 or something like
that but then again is that 2.5 k which
where does that fall either way it
doesn't really matter all we know is
it's higher than 1080p and i'm glad to
see oppo as a company pushing the limits
yet again here now i know what a lot of
you guys are thinking because i've seen
it in the tweets i've seen it in the
comments in other videos
it's why would i want a 2k display in my
smartphone if i already have a 1080p
display i already can't see the pixels
it already looks super sharp why would i
want extra resolution that's just going
to kill battery life that's just going
to hinder graphics performance just
going to make the phone less enjoyable
to use why would anyone want a 2k
display and it's so easy to just ignore
that tweet and agree with that it's so
easy to just
not care basically
but if you rewind to september 2012
i made a video in september 2012 called
the super retina display smartphone
about a company called oppo who was
preparing to release a revolutionary
1080p smartphone if you look back at a
lot of those older comments a lot of the
comments on that old video remind me
exactly of the reactions to oppo's tweet
where people are saying
1080p on a smartphone are you kidding me
why would i want that i can already not
see the pixels on my iphone it already
has a retina display why would i want a
1080p smartphone that's just going to
wreck my performance that's just going
to hinder my battery life and at first
it really did they were right the first
1080p smartphones like the oppo find 5
and the droid dna
they were really not the best
performance they needed like top end
specs uh and massive batteries to keep
up with the phones that didn't have
1080p displays
and their sales showed they weren't the
best selling phones they weren't the
best experience even though they had
those amazing new
bright beautiful looking panels
but slowly the big guns came on the the
htc ones the galaxy s4s the sony xperia
zs the nexus 5s suddenly we have all
these massive 1080p phones and it's sort
of a standard by now we kind of expect a
new high-end smartphone to have a 1080p
display by the end of 2013. and actually
something funny happened a moto x came
out that was supposed to be a flagship
for motorola and it had a 720p display
and there were comments from people who
said
why doesn't this have a 1080p display
how is this supposed to be a flagship
without a 1080p display so it's clear
that 1080p has become a standard it's
become what we expect out of every new
phone and it's obvious that a 1080p
phone nowadays compared to last
generation 720p phones the 1080p phone
looks a lot better and even more obvious
when you put a 1080p phone next to an
iphone no offense to the iphone but it
has a 640p display and you can
definitely tell which one is the 1080p
display when you put them side by side
the phone with a 1080p display is going
to look a lot better than a phone with a
640p display even though you already
can't see the pixels on that 640p
display because it's about so much more
than just raw pixels now it's almost
like the megapixel count in cameras it's
way more than just pixels now that's so
much more than just that if i sat you
down 10 feet away from 250 inch tvs
one of them is a 1080p tv and the other
one is a 4k tv and asks you which one
looks better 10 times out of 10 you're
going to say that the 4k tv looks better
even though you can't see the pixels on
either one of them from 10 feet away you
can still tell that that 4k tv looks
immensely better and i've done this test
for myself i went to ces 2013 i will be
at ces 2014 again to see way more 4k tvs
but you can tell that a 4k tv of the
same size as a 1080p tv looks way
better even though you can't see the
pixels on any of them so this same
philosophy is being applied here by oppo
to smartphones you can make a display
that looks better than a 1080p display
even though you already can't see the
pixels on the 1080p display so i'm ready
to see that i'm ready and it looks like
oppo is going to be the one to do it
either they're first or they're one of
the first now will it impact battery
life at first
probably will it negatively hurt your
graphics performance at first
probably but oppo is willing to take
that risk again and you know i admire
them for that they're willing to be the
ice breaker just dive in head first be
the number one uh and push that boundary
and that's that's impressive of setting
standards is not easy but i can kind of
see that same trend as we saw before
happening with this 2k resolution over
the next few months the big guns started
getting into it you know big players the
new galaxy s5 comes out with a 2k
display galaxy note 4
htc 2
nexus six
uh
and then maybe we'll see a motorola
phone that comes out with this 1080p
display that makes everyone scratch
their heads why is it only 1080p you
know what i mean crazy it might happen
it might just happen it's all about
framing really and i guess basically
what i'm trying to say with this whole
video is that uh
that no one should really be complaining
when it comes to the when it comes to
the future of of technologies like this
like the really high tech stuff uh when
we're seeing like for example really
high resolutions and smartphones there's
no real reason to complain unless you
know maybe you buy a smartphone with a
2k display and your battery life sucks
then complain please complain because
that's that's going to make the
technology better but there's always
going to be the naysayers in the infancy
of any new technology growing pains as i
like to call it but uh don't complain
unless it's actually hurting you like th
just let it happen let oppo take the
bold steps like let whoever wants to
follow and their foot trails take the
next bold steps
i guess i'm probably just rambling at
this point i wrote this really quickly
and i wanted to tell you guys it but
anyway that's basically it yeah if you
enjoyed this video feel free to give it
a thumbs up i'm excited like i said to
see the fine seven by the way
i hope this isn't a gigantic phone oppo
i you could say it's 2560 by 1600 but if
it's a seven inch phone
not working out um but yeah i'm excited
because the rest of the fine seven specs
that have leaked have been along the
lines of like 15 megapixel camera 4 000
milliamp hour battery snapdragon 805 or
803 next generation chip uh like three
or four gigs of ram just crazy stuff so
i'm excited for the future of mobile
phones and it's the end of 2013 the
beginning of 2014 is gonna bring more
awesome stuff i'm rambling again thanks
for watching
subscribe if you haven't already and
i'll talk to you guys in the next video
peace
you